well uh tell us Chris uh first of all
nice to meet you and where are you right
now I'm in Chico California Chico
California and um oh look at your books
behind you you got World War II the
Civil War uh we could be friends you and
I we have similar interest I can tell
like you you're always talking about
like at the end of your show you're like
you know like we're friends in the
podcast we're not friends outside I got
a got feeling we'd be friends in real
life without question or doubt well
first of all I love you got some red in
your hair you got the cool stash cool
must I like mustache right there um and
you got a good broadcaster voice you got
a very good I appreciate that thank you
con yeah do what's your profession are
you you a guy that like does a paramedic
oh you're a paramedic oh my God yeah I
I'd very much like to be a broadcaster
but no I'm a paramedic for now oh yeah
you're only saving lives right now yeah
you're really tell more people I'm sure
Chris let me assure you what you're
doing is so much cooler than uh than any
broadcaster I know that is very cool
tell us what it's like to be what's it
like to be a paramedic tell us about it
uh it's very rewarding at times um it is
it is the biggest compliment I Reed in
my life is being welcomed into stranger
home during their time of and the only
way I can repay that is like by doing my
best okay um it's extremely rewarding at
times and at times it is absolutely
difficult very difficult when you first
show up you go in the room let's say you
you enter the house you go in and I
guess the first job is to try and
ascertain what is wrong with this person
right yeah why did you call 911 today
okay I always introduce myself if uh
it's available as a paramedic and I say
you know Hi how are you doing what made
you call 911 today are you any pain
what's going on and we kind of have to
go down the route of is it a medical
problem or is it a traumatic problem and
then from there we uh treat diagnos the
best for ability and transfer them to
the appropriate Hospital wow this is you
you are uh first of all it sounds like
you're very calm in these situations
right it just you I am I'm more nervous
about this and I have ever been like
there'll be like there's blood
everywhere on the radio I'll just be
calm as a cucumber but there like Lisa
was just telling me like con's on in two
and I'm sweating okay all right well
listen maybe you need a paramedic you
should you should call someone right now
why did you call 911 I'm on the phone
with con' Brien it may be kind of
nervous I won't be the first I won't be
the last um so uh okay you a paramedic
and you you go and you don't have to
call me sir just call me Admiral um but
ad you go into their home and let's say
you notice okay this person's got a real
problem and you uh put him in the
ambulance and then you take him to the
emergency room does you just drop them
off then or or is there a handoff to the
trauma Sur there is a hand off report
and the handoff report is one of the
most valuable things I can provide on
most calls um I have access to like the
patient's house I have access to or the
side of the the road I can see what
happened to the patient I can see their
living circumstances and I can tell them
to the nurse and uh doctor as well uh so
in the I'm usually as the paramedic I
work alongside an EMT the EMT generally
speaking is the one that drives and
assists me U while we're not driving and
I'm in the back and I provide um a
higher level of care uh I provide uh you
know IV Therapy cardiac Monitor and I
have a list of medications I can give if
appropriate what wow just I didn't know
the we go to an appropriate hospital or
different destinations a hospital and
myself or sometimes I have to call a
doctor and decide which appropriate
hospital or which hospital is
appropriate for this patient wow do you
ever give the uh guy driving attitude
that you have all these other
responsibilities every day
yeah I would I'd be like hey how's the
driving going forunate I'm back here uh
giving medications and saving lives hey
you might nice left turn the guy's
Bleeding Out
bragging I would I would spend all my
time bragging my my uh my my I'm going
to turn you up I'm sorry my partner I
have the greatest EMT partner in the
world he uh we work really well together
he constantly challenges me um he's
constantly asking me questions about
this that the other thing his name's
Talon he listens the podcast too okay
well Tom said hey shout out what's his
name again shout out Talon like a claw
his name is Talon
whoa the ever yeah now I like him better
why am I talking to Talon yeah Chris you
got to step work right now I had to get
my ship
covers
Rapier as in Rapier with that's don't
call me terrible terrible Nick really
bad that one was really bad stiletto
yeah that's not like something like
about like his stash like we'll call him
the broom oh God you guys are so bad at
this the broom go you go knife okay okay
okay well that's all better than my real
nickname what's your what's your real
Rain Man work they call you Rainman
really yeah oh yeah I I played trivia
with my uh with my oh you're good at
trivia that's all right good trivia and
chess if they're mocking you for being
uh intelligent and having knowledge uh
that's okay you know I'm sure you know
the feel I'm sorry I mean seriously I've
been mocked in the past but uh so what
if I can't throw a baseball anyway let's
not dwell on that last time I threw
baseball I had to call an EMT um so uh
you get to the hospital you have the
patient sir
um do you have to say like okay here's
what I think it is does the does the
surgeon ever have a real attitude like I
think I'll figure this out do they ever
do that like I think I got it from
forunate yeah they went to seven years
of school I went to one yeah there's a
big difference but I'm very fortunate
again the hospital I work in a
association with is uh we have some very
fantastic doctors I I choose to work
where I work uh because I work with a
lot of really great people including the
doctors and nurses other First
Responders in my area uh come on isn't
anyone in your life a prick I mean come
on that's why you called here are there
are I have the utmost respect for
everyone I encounter there's got to be
one person at the hospital who's just
the worst we won't name them but you
know who I'm talking isn't very
nice oh good lord anyway uh moving on um
so I'm just picturing him in All denim
scrubs so I hear you having a heart
attack um um that's his
siren
me